bonjour je vais vous parler des lumières
du grenier c'est le titre que nous avons
choisie pour le programme de grands
films classiques que nous avons concocté
pour la saison 2007 2016 2017
vous pourrez aussi évidemment voir des
films de patrimoine d'enchaîner hausse
initiale cinéma voisin
la soirée d'ouverture de la saison au
grenier à sel aura lieu le vendredi 30
septembre à 20h45 avec un ce soit ainsi
les concerts sur les films burlesques de
charlie bauer charlie bauer c'est un des
génies du début du cinéma au même titre
que chaplin keaton ou même méliès
sauf que lui l'histoire l'a un peu
oublié donc ces films sont toujours
fantastique et nous allons les
redécouvrir grâce à franck ionale
fonctional c'est un musicien batteur qui
a qui accompagnera les courts métrages à
la batterie solo et grâce à une bande
son
sur ordinateur qu'il a créé sur
ordinateur donc monsieur bricolo c'est
un inventeur loufoque
l'accompagnement musical proposé par
fractional mettra en lumière l'audace de
ce savant fou en passant de l'électro à
la musique girling et de l'afrobeat au
rock
le titre du film je l'ait pas dit mais
le titre du programme c'est les fois
l'invention de monsieur bricolo les
tarifs c'est 6 euros le tarif normal
mais si vous êtes si vous avez un
abonnement cinéma ce sera à 3 euros pour
vous pensez donc à réserver au 01 30 69
84 62 et vous retrouverez évidemment
plus d'informations sur cinéma grenier à
sel point com